this for what?
To the truth.
>> Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
>> This is one video. If you care about the
dunya more than skip it. By one
donation, you're going to help 1.8
million people in need. 551,000 people
who've been fed through the emergency
food aid. You are going to be sponsoring
4,200 orphans. You will be helping
250,000 people in Gaza. You'll be
helping 123,000 people to be fed through
our Kulmani program. You will help feed
551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 massages that are going to be built
around the world and 74,000 given clean
safe water. That's why we want to keep
one um 100% donation policy. And in
order for us to keep 100, we need you to
help us by supporting this fund so that
all of the stuff that I mentioned, you
get the reward for every single one of
them is far more important than the
dunya. And you will see every penny that
you give on your makama. The decision is
yours. The link is there. Donate now.
>> Hello, my friend. Free copy.
>> Free copy of the Quran.
>> Quran. Serious.
>> You want free copy?
>> Not in the Quran.
>> Oh, no. Why not?
>> We're [__] British.
>> I'm I'm British, too.
>> But why is the Quran?
>> This is Give it to people.
>> You're being [__]
>> nice.
This for what?
>> To the truth.
>> Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey. to the
truth.
>> Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Sorry, sorry, sorry. Sorry, sorry.
What are you doing?
scumbag.
>> Where's the
scumbag?
>> Well, they'll they'll never stop the
scumbag.
We're having a nice conversation.
Ali.
>> Yeah.
To alert you. To alert you. They coming.
They I saw them there. They were
>> I didn't see him. No, he can talk. But
he's coming in front of our face. Quran
challenging. You need to fight.
>> Scumbag man. Flipping
>> idiot. You see what he done? Took the
Quran. Bang. No. No. He's talking. He
took the Quran and he goes bang.
>> Scumbag. If you talk, talk. If you can
come here to if you can go and come and
get the Quran's idiot,
>> you know she he can come and talk. He
comes here, he grabs the Quran and he's
he throws it on the floor.
>> This do if you don't you know this guy
if you don't do enough he's going to
think he can come and do that casually
>> flipping coward. He just one behind you.
>> Huh?
>> Just put his middle finger on
>> where he's gone.
>> They can piss it piss off, man. They can
get lost, bro. You see people like this,
they think they can do that and get
away. I'm not another D table, bro. No
doubt. You're going to come here and
think you're just going to do dumb stuff
like cuz you're drunk. I don't care,
man. Flipping coward.
567 £567, guys. Let's go.
Listen. They think they're going to stop
the Dow. You're going to never stop the
Dow, bro.